first tonight an update on the saga of
General Michael Flynn like so much else
that has happened recently in America
the Flynn's story lays bare the
architecture of control that's been
present just beneath the surface of this
country for a long time for reasons we
still don't fully understand Michael
Flynn deeply offended permanent
Washington somehow so they decided to
destroy him they pretended to believe he
was a secret Russian agent and then they
entrapped him on a completely bogus
perjury charge when he resisted they
threatened to hurt his son until he
signed a confession it sounds like
something that happens in China it
happened here in the middle of our
capital city Washington we've known that
for a long time what we didn't know was
that there is an extensive written
record that proves all of this happened
and in fact the truth is worse even than
we guessed according to newly released
documents On January 4th 2017 FBI agents
decided to close their investigation of
Michael Flynn and his ties to Russia
after much searching they had found
quote no derogatory information about
Flynn so it was over he was in the clear
but it wasn't over corrupt FBI official
Peter struck demanded that the
investigation stay open until the bureau
could invent a crime and crush Michael
Flynn and in the end that's what
happened there is nothing worse than
this
it's how the secret police operate in
third-world dictatorships and it's
exactly how Peter struck operated and
then he lied about it extensively listen
to structs greasy self-righteousness in
congressional testimony two years ago
not once in my 26 years of defending our
nation did my personal opinions impact
any official action I took this is true
for the Clinton email investigation for
the investigation into Russian
interference and for every other
investigation I've worked on it is not
who I am
and it is not something I would ever do
period I understand that my sworn
testimony will not be enough for some
people
after all Americans are skeptical of
anything coming out of Washington but
fact is after months of investigations
there's simply no evidence of bias in my
professional actions what an oleaginous
liar he should be in prison
literally and in fact if the FBI treated
its own officials the way it treats its
political opponents Peter struck would
be serving a multi year sentence for the
statement you just saw pretty much
everything he said in Congress was
perjury but that's not what happened
instead the FBI continued to let Peter
struck metal in American politics in our
democracy the one they claim they're
protecting it was struck who decided
that Hillary Clinton's secret email
server was merely extremely careless
instead of grossly negligent the
distinction was between a crime and not
a crime he let her off the hook it was
struck who bragged to his mistress about
building a quote insurance policy
against Trump's election and promising
to quote stop him
meaning Trump in January of 2017 it was
struck who kept the bogus Russia
investigation going hey he wrote to a
colleague on January 4th don't close
razor that was the internal name for the
Michael Flynn investigation that very
same day struck sent out a 14 page
document about an obscure law called the
Logan Act the Logan Act has been around
for 200 years
it bans private citizens from conducting
diplomacy with foreign countries no one
in American history has ever been
convicted of violating the Logan Act in
fact the last indictment under the Logan
Act was before the Civil War in fact the
law may be unconstitutional none of that
mattered to Peter struck the Logan Act
was the weapon to bash Michael Flynn
that same day struck texted his
girlfriend quote razor still open
serendipitously good I guess you want
those chips and Oreos she replied that's
amazing that he is still open good I
guess at this point it was over for
Michael Flynn that we didn't know it the
FBI arranged an interview with Flynn at
the White House he had no idea what was
coming according to handwritten notes
FBI officials plotted to quote get him
to lie so he can prosecute him or get
him fired it worked
Flynn Mustaine in a fact about a
meaningless phone call with the Russian
ambassador the F
the I had spied on that phone call so
they knew Flynn's life was over his
family was destroyed in late 2018 after
he had already cashed it on his book
bragging about himself former FBI
director Jim Comey laughed about how
easy it was to set Flynn up look at this
White House now and it's hard to imagine
two FBI agents ending up in the same
room how did that happen
I sent them something we probably
wouldn't have done or maybe gotten away
with in a more organized investigation a
more organized administration I thought
it's early enough let's just send a
couple guys over and so we placed a call
to Flynn said hey we're sending a couple
guys over hope you'll talk to them he
said sure
nobody else was there they interviewed
him in a conference room at the White
House Situation Room and he lied to them
and that's what he's now pled guilty to
what did he think they were coming over
there for I don't think he knew I know
we didn't tell him oh it's all pretty
funny destroying someone's life and
destroying his family because they're in
the way of the power you seek you would
have to be a dark cold person to chuckle
about something like that and Jim Comey
definitely is the darkest and the
coldest we want to be clear at this
point that we're not personally close to
Michael Flynn he's not some secret
friend of this show this isn't about one
man it's about our country you don't
want to live in a society where the most
powerful agency and government imprisons
people it doesn't like that is
horrifying people come to this country
to escape it but it happened and if it
can happen to a three-star general
serving as the National Security Advisor
it could definitely without question
happen to you